[Música]
y
masiva movilización en argentina en
rechazo al atentado que pretendía acabar
con la vida de la vicepresidenta
cristina fernández de kirchner para que
fuera también presidenta de la nación ya
entregó declaraciones en la
investigación que se abrió por el
intento de magnicidio la gran incógnita
sigue siendo los motivos del sospechoso
detenido
rusia no restablecerá el envío de gas
este fin de semana a través del
gasoducto nord stream 1 que se extiende
hasta alemania la suspensión de tres
días por mantenimiento se va a prolongar
debido a una fuga en una turbina según
informó gazprom su operadora alemán ya
calificó el anuncio como guerra
psicológica
la agencia espacial nasa se prepara para
el segundo intento de lanzamiento de la
misión artemis uno que busca poner una
cápsula en órbita de la luna como prueba
para un eventual regreso del ser humano
a ese satélite se espera la asistencia
de unas 400 mil personas en cabo
cañaveral
actualizamos las noticias en la pantalla
de france 24 gracias por continuar con
nosotros yo soy juan rubiales empezamos
esta emisión en argentina en donde fue
un día de masivas movilizaciones para
repudiar el atentado que pretendía
acabar con la vida de la vicepresidenta
cristina fernández de kirchner la
antigua mandataria ya prestó su
declaración en medio de las
investigaciones mientras que el acusado
quien intentó disparar este jueves sin
éxito a fernández se negó a declarar de
nuevo el expediente figura como
homicidio calificado en grado de
tentativa pero no se descarta ninguna
hipótesis
previamente hablamos con nuestro
corresponsal en buenos aires- en natal
yo soy quien nos entregó más detalles
sobre las pesquisas
hola que tal buenas noches fue una
jornada de una gran movilización ahora
me encuentro junto a la puerta del
domicilio de cristina fernández de
kirchner ella no está aquí y salió más
temprano pero todavía quedan algunas
pocas personas aquí la movilización más
grande fue a la plaza de mayo frente a
la casa de gobierno sí fue realmente
masiva una movilización muy muy grande
en apoyo a la vicepresidente y en
rechazo a este ataque fallido que sufrió
el día jueves respecto a las
investigaciones avanzan las
investigaciones de la justicia se fueron
tomando la jueza y el fiscal fueron
tomando declaraciones a lo largo del día
a varios de los testigos incluso se
trasladaron hasta aquí hasta este lugar
y aquí hablaron con la vicepresidenta
cristina fernández según medios locales
ella dijo que en el momento del disparo
que es algo que hemos visto mucho y
repetidas veces ella no se dio cuenta de
lo que ocurría algo que parecía verse en
imagen y otro dato importante que
también están dando medios locales es
que la jueza el fiscal fueron a tomar
declaración al hombre que intentó es que
gatilló ese arma intentó disparar contra
la vicepresidenta y él decidió no dar
ninguna declaración hasta ahora diríamos
que son los detalles más salientes de la
investigación hasta el momento siempre
esperando que se sepa cuál pudo haber
sido el motivo de este ataque y si fue
algo que hizo por su cuenta si estuvo
ayudado por alguien más si forma parte
de una organización o no que son cosas
que todavía no tienen respuesta
vamos a colombia porque ocho policías
fueron asesinados en una emboscada que
tuvo lugar en una zona rural en el
departamento del huila en el sur
occidente del país el hecho fue
confirmado por el propio presidente
gustavo petro quien ya se desplazó hasta
la región e indicó que los autores del
ataque no han sido identificados según
los primeros reportes en las víctimas
serían dos subtenientes dos patrulleros
y cuatro auxiliares los policías lleven
de regreso a una comisaría local a la
que estaban adscritos tras haber
participado en una jornada de trabajo
cuando fue activado un campo minado el
paso de la patrulla que los transportaba
rechazó contundentemente el ataque con
explosivos donde murieron ocho policías
en san luís uy la solidaridad con sus
familias estos hechos expresan un claro
saboteo a la paz total he pedido a las
autoridades desplazarse al territorio
para asumir la investigación los
habitantes de haití el país más pobre de
américa deben sortear día a día el
hambre la escasez de combustible y la
violencia de grupos criminales que se
disputan territorios en este contexto el
gobierno ha implementado ciertos cambios
para disminuir el costo de los alimentos
pero no han sido suficientes
andrés granadillo nos tiene los detalles
una crisis que no cesa los haitianos
acostumbrados a vivir entre las
adversidades se enfrentan al hambre
la vida es dura para mí no puedo comprar
comida no puedo comprar nada tengo un
negocio pero la gente no viene a comprar
el gobierno había anunciado medidas para
reducir el precio de los alimentos pero
hasta el momento no han surtido efecto
marc y trabaja en el mercado de tabarre
y no percibe cambios
pero sigue siendo caro solo el precio de
las judías ha disminuido más o menos el
precio de un saco de arroz se vende a
tres mil kurdos las autoridades
reconocen que la situación económica es
preocupante las previsiones son de una
desaceleración del 0,4 por ciento según
el ministerio de finanzas la inflación
ronda el 29 por ciento la más alta de
los últimos 10 años y además de estas
perspectivas preocupantes en las calles
las bandas criminales luchan por el
control territorial mantienen bloqueos
en la entrada del sur de puerto príncipe
aislando cuatro departamentos del país
en estos sitios se encuentran los
productores de bienes que abastecen a la
capital
unas 3.000 personas han quedado
desplazadas debido a la violencia
algunos de ellos se han ido a la vecina
república dominicana y otros a eeuu
buscando un futuro a pesar de parecer
tener todo en contra los haitianos
siguen resistiendo
alemania lo calificó como guerra
psicológica mientras que otros países de
europa lo consideraron como una jugada
política hablamos de la decisión del
consorcio ruso from the mantener
suspendido el suministro de gas a través
del nord stream 1 la empresa hizo su
anuncio tan solo un día antes de
reanudar la operación que se mantiene en
torno al 20 por ciento de su capacidad
esta operación había sido suspendida por
tres días para realizar labores de
mantenimiento y ahora seguirá inactiva
hasta nuevo anuncio
y van a ser sólo tres días pero ahora el
gasoducto nord stream 1 que transporta
gas ruso a europa quedará cerrado
indefinidamente por culpa de unas
reparaciones
así lo informaba el gigante energético
gazprom
según la información de siemens la
eliminación completa de las fugas de
aceite en estos motores sólo es posible
en las condiciones de un taller de
reparación hasta que no se eliminen las
advertencias sobre el funcionamiento de
los equipos el transporte de gas al
gasoducto nord stream estará
completamente parado
rusia alega que las sanciones europeas
por la guerra en ucrania impiden hacerle
buen mantenimiento al gasoducto que ya
estaba parado desde hace dos días
también debido a supuestas reparaciones
disminuyendo así significativamente la
cantidad de gas que llega a alemania y
se distribuye por el resto de países
europeos y encareciendo todavía más los
precios de la electricidad en los países
del bloque comunitario
con la interrupción total anunciada este
viernes la situación solo puede empeorar
la unión europea sigue afirmando que
rusia usa su gas como venganza contra el
apoyo occidental a ucrania
el anuncio de gazprom de esta tarde
sobre el nuevo cierre del nord stream 1
bajo argumentos falaces es otra
confirmación de su poca fiabilidad como
proveedor también demuestra el sí mismo
de rusia que prefiere quemar gas a
honrar sus contratos el nuevo órdago
ruso llega precisamente en el momento en
el que los líderes europeos se preparan
para limitar los precios de la energía
una estrategia que ayudaría a su
población a sobrellevar la crisis que se
avecina pero que reduciría los ingresos
rusos
a lo largo de esta jornada fueron
registrados enfrentamientos cerca de la
central nuclear de shapur y allá en
ucrania considerada la central nuclear
más grandes de europa esto coincide con
la visita a las instalaciones de una
misión del organismo internacional de
energía atómica oiea
seis de los catorce integrantes de este
equipo van a permanecer en la central en
la que habrá custodia de seguridad
permanente en el lugar según indicó el
director del organismo en rafael grossi
de la oea espera presentar un informe
completo de sus hallazgos la próxima
semana aunque desde viena austria sede
de la oea gross y entregó detalles
acerca de sus primeras impresiones
primero está en la integridad física de
las instalaciones lo que ven aquí es un
rojo rojo grande porque es un rojo
grande porque todavía hemos estado
viendo actividad militar alrededor de la
planta pudimos ver agujeros de impacto
en el equipo marcas en edificios
proyectiles esto significa que la
integridad física de la instalación ha
sido violada no una sino varias veces
el segundo pilar se refiere a que el
sistema de seguridad y protección esté
en pleno funcionamiento lo evaluamos con
un amarillo porque la mayoría de ellos
están funcionando relativamente bien
pero ha habido interrupciones algunas de
ellas relacionadas con la rotura física
de los cables o en algunas conexiones y
también en algunos sistemas que no están
completamente en su lugar por lo que no
podemos obtener la información completa
que el informe en francia la comunidad
chilena se moviliza en las últimas
jornadas previas el plebiscito de este
domingo sobre la nueva constitución los
mandos de aprobación y rechazo
aprovechan las últimas horas para
convencer y promover las opciones
nuestra compañera erika olavarría estuvo
con estas campañas
estuvo brevemente en francia
participando de un festival por la
ecología
[Aplausos]
y el comando por el apruebo en parís
invitó a la lingüista mapuche a un
banderazo a favor del proyecto de
constitución
elisa loncón que presido durante meses
la comisión encargada de la redacción
del texto constitucional defiende el
trabajo realizado
aquí me he dado cuenta
[Música]
porque nuestro país
es nueva
en democracia que tiene el consenso
y de todas incluyendo los malos los
indígenas exiliados de la dictadura de
pinochet o jóvenes que vinieron
recientemente por trabajo o estudios los
chilenos en francia mantienen más que
nunca el vínculo con su país en un
momento histórico sigue siendo nuestro
país lo segundo y quizás más importante
es que la nueva constitución nos da
nuevos derechos a nosotros como chileno
en el extranjero mañana vamos a poder
incluso tener nuestros diputados desde
el extranjero un chat de whatsapp es la
manera en que los partidarios del
rechazo en francia han elegido para
compartir ideas antes del domingo lo
creó bernardo abogado que está detrás
también de otras iniciativas como la
homologación del carné de conducir
chileno en francia
en la convención constituyente no fue
quien quiere criticar nadie etcétera
pero no fue un reflejo de lo que es
chile y un país democrático un país
hemos tenido una tradición de diálogo y
respecto al contenido que mucha gente no
se ha sentido identificada con el tema
como la plurinacionalidad a con respecto
a la igualdad de la ley el hecho de que
se categorizó un poco los chilenos por
su origen no sabemos cómo esto va a ser
puesto en la ley y en la vida cotidiana
los chilenos más de 20 mil chilenos
viven en este país es el noveno que
acoge más chilenos en el mundo unos
3.000 se han inscrito para votar pero al
haber sólo dos locales de sufragio el
voto no es obligatorio
la nasa se alista nuevamente para el
lanzamiento de su misión espacial
'artemis' 1 prevista para este sábado
dicha misión haya sido cancelada el
lunes debido a problemas técnicos la
misión de prueba es la antesala para
llevarse a los humanos de vuelta a la
luna y en un futuro cercano al planeta
marte andrés triviño tiene el informe
listos para el despegue la nasa dijo que
la misión artemis 1 sin tripulación
tendrá otro intento de lanzamiento para
realizar su viaje alrededor de la luna
este sábado con pronósticos
meteorológicos favorables y si todo sale
como se espera
el cohete despegará del centro espacial
kennedy en cabo cañaveral florida a las
14 y 17 hora local la misión pretende
lanzar el cohete más potente del mundo y
lleva aproximadamente una década en
desarrollo artemis requiere de un vuelo
de prueba sin tripulación de seis
semanas alrededor de la luna
[Música]
este es un vuelo de prueba y aunque me
siento muy bien con nuestros
procedimientos cuando miras al equipo a
los ojos están listos no podemos
controlar el clima etcétera cualquier
día existe el riesgo de no poder
despegar lo importante es que nuestro
equipo está listo guard y el lanzamiento
genera emoción en el público y tan solo
algunos podrán estar dentro del
auditorio kennedy muchos pretenden estar
en cocoa beach a unos kilómetros del
centro espacial para ver el
acontecimiento histórico la agencia se
vio obligada a posponer el lanzamiento
de artemio programados para el pasado 29
de agosto tras registrar problemas
técnicos a última hora
nunca he visto nunca hemos visto ningún
lanzamiento así que eso es muy
emocionante aunque hayamos tenido que
regresar a
artemis sucesora de las misiones lunares
apolo de los años 60 y 70 es tan sólo el
comienzo de un programa que tendrá como
objetivo el regreso de los seres humanos
a la luna y con el tiempo el aterrizaje
de misiones tripuladas a marte
[Música]
terminamos con el festival de venecia el
protagonismo hoy fue para el actor
franco estadounidense tim mote salame y
la premier de su más reciente
largometraje bones en compañía de
tenedor basel ambos protagonizan una
historia de amor entre dos caníbales
afligidos asienta supone el reencuentro
entre llamar el director luca guadagnino
con quien trabajó en común y bayern en
una película que impulsó a nivel
internacional la carrera de este actor
de 26 años
[Música]
así terminamos esta emisión informativa
en la pantalla de france 24 pero
quédense en nuestra señal la información
continúa aquí y también pueden visitar
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
[Música]